we're often in situations of wanting to
help
and be kind to other people but of not
quite knowing what they might be in need
of
we'd like to deepen our connection to
them and be of service and yet we lack a
real grasp of what we could plausibly
offer them
their minds seem impenetrable their
problems opaque
at such moments we would do well to
remember that we all possess
a superpower a capacity to give people
something we can be sure
they fundamentally require founded on a
primordial
and basic insight into human nature that
all of us
are in deep need of reassurance
life is a more or less ongoing emergency
for everyone
we are invariably haunted by doubts
about our value
by concerns for our future by shapeless
anxiety and dread about things we've
done
by feelings of guilt and embarrassment
about ourselves
every day brings new threats to our
integrity and except for very rare
moments
when we and the world feel solid there
is almost always a background throb of
unwellness in our minds
it doesn't matter whether they're old or
young accomplished or starting out
at the top of the tree or struggling to
get by we can count on
one thing about anyone we meet they'll
be beset by a sense of insecurity
and beneath some excellent camouflage to
a greater or lesser extent
of desperation that means that more than
they perhaps even realize
they will be longing for someone to say
something soothing to them
a word or two to make them feel that
they have a right to exist
that we have some faith in them that we
know things aren't always
easy for them and that in a vague but
real way
we're on their side it could be a very
small and
barely perceptible remark but its effect
might be critical
maybe that something fascinating they
said sticks in our minds
that we know the past few months might
not have been simple for them
that we found ourselves thinking of them
since our last meeting
that we've noticed and admire the way
they go about things
that they deserve a break and that they
are we can see
carrying so much it's easy to mistake
the work of reassurance
with flattery but flattery involves a
lie
to gain advantage whereas reassurance
involves revealing genuine affection
which we normally leave out from
embarrassment
in order to bolster someone's ability to
endure
we flatter in order to extract benefit
we reassure
in order to help furthermore the
flatterer tells their prey about their
strengths
the reassurer does something infinitely
more valuable
they hint that they've seen the
weaknesses but have only
tolerance and compassion for them on the
basis of sharing fully
incomparable examples i think you're
going to be fine
everyone goes through things like these
you've got nothing to be ashamed of the
words we need to say to reassure
aren't new they can be the most
apparently banal of sentences
but we need to keep hearing them because
our minds are extremely bad
at holding on to their nourishing truths
they are furthermore
lines that are a great deal more
valuable and inclined to stick
if someone else addresses them to us
than if we try to rehearse them
by ourselves in 1425 the florentine
artist
masaccio painted a rendition of adam and
eve's expulsion from the garden of eden
on the walls of florence's church of
santa maria del camine
we need not believe in any of the
supernatural aspects of genesis
to be profoundly moved by the
horror-stricken faces of the banished
couple
and if we are so it's because what we
see is a version of an agony that is
essentially
universal for all of us have effectively
been cast out of the realm of comfort
and plenty
and obliged to dwell in the lands of
uncertainty
humiliation and grief all of us are
beset by woes
all of us are worried to the core
longing for rest
and in urgent need of forbearance and
gentleness
part of the responsibility of living in
a time that broadly no longer believes
in divine reassurance
is that we are each of us given a role
to play in delivering
part of that reassurance ourselves to
our fellow sufferers
in ordinary moments of our ordinary
lives
we cannot generally know the precise
details of other people's travails
but we can always be sure of a few vital
things from the outset
that they are at some level in a mood of
pain and self-suspicion
that certain very big things will not
have gone right
that there will be intensities of
loneliness anxiety
and shame at play and that it could
hence make a very big difference
indeed if we were able to say something
however modest and even unoriginal
to bring a little reassurance into their
day
if you enjoyed our film please subscribe
to our channel
and click the bell icon to turn on
notifications
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most
important and often neglected areas of
life
click now to learn more